[Music]
clayton's with us clayton is in portland
oregon hi clayton how can dr john and i
help
hi guys it's nice to speak with you you
too
um i saw you in yours in the smart
conference of sacramento my wife and i
went down before the pandemic and so
it's really fun to be able to see that
and be a part of that well thank you
we're doing another one finally in
dallas in the fall october 22nd maybe
you can come down for it yeah we'd love
to
so i do have a question um i have grown
siblings my wife and i are doing pretty
well we're on baby step six
and uh our annual combined salary is
around two hundred thousand
um
we'll have
close to six hundred thousand therefore
we both have opinions you know we're
doing really well so we only have 155 on
our
house and it's worth over 400. wow
so the question that i have is with my
siblings
my sister and i were adopted when we
were little
my mom proceeded to have two more
siblings
after we were adopted out
and we recently got in contact with them
about four years ago so we're all in our
50s
now and
the trauma from
being in an alcoholic home has really
caused a lot of damage over the years
the three other siblings don't really
have a whole lot going on financially or
otherwise
but
the problem for my wife and i is because
we're doing so well
we feel bad
when we can't help them or we don't help
them
you know with finances or anything like
that and we feel like we're doing wrong
when we do because we feel like we're
enabling
the situation so i guess we just need
some guidance on
how to deal with that situation
that's hard man i'm so sorry
well
um that's the beginning of our story i
mean we haven't finished yet our story's
still going so yeah i mean i she was
pretty rough i mean she did they did
they call you do they i mean did they
call you and hit you up for money how
does that interaction work um it's small
stuff it's usually i can't meet the i
can't meet the expenses like um one of
my brothers
couldn't pay for his rent and then
another one when we went to see
our brother he uh didn't have enough
money to get back home
and then my sister i've been helping her
for years with money because she's just
now she's disabled
and she gets a disability check but she
just doesn't have she isn't able to make
ends meet you know so
it's a really tough situation for us you
know i get up at 4am and go to work
every day i have i'm 30 years at the
same job and so
we earn that money and we feel like
we're doing the right thing but we just
need to know
where to put or what to do with all that
so
we're kind of at a loss
as far as
is it okay to help them or
are we enabling that behavior do we you
know i don't i don't know them well
enough to just speak on
their lives yeah except this
when somebody invites themselves into
your life to ask you for your resources
that is permission as far as i'm
concerned
to then
speak on the utilization of that money
right how is this money helping or
hurting somebody yeah if if you have the
guts to ask me for money i have the guts
to tell you how to use it because it's
mine right
and the idea that you're a bank account
or a blank check for other people
that's complete dysfunction that's right
that's right that's just guilty well
there's no doubt that dysfunction's
there we're all native american and
in the native american community it's
it's a different it's kind of a
different dynamic because we really give
i mean we try to absolutely my heart is
a giving heart you know and i feel bad
you know when i don't so here's the
thing
here's the thing
you use the word help
and when you're giving you should
help
so you need to define help
differently
help is not giving a drunk a drink
that's enabling that's not help
help is not participating in funding
someone's delusions or craziness or
misbehavior that's not help so if when
you give them money if as a result of
you giving them money
they're not better
then you didn't help
you made yourself feel better for a few
days and you made them feel better for a
few days and now they go back to the
exact same behavior
that's not a native american thing
that's an enabling thing
in any culture
so you're not
helping
when you give a drunk a drink
and that's the classic line about
enabling you're not helping enabling
when i'm when i'm an enabler and i'm not
very often but i have been at times
i get caught in some kind of crossfire
some kind of triangulation or something
and i feel
like i'm caught and i've got to do this
and i feel trapped and it's it's all a
false premise but i get myself in there
just like everybody else does
it and and i feel like i'm helping but
they're not better when i'm done
then i that they didn't move along to a
better life you know then i didn't
really help
it's kind of like telling people what
they want to hear
just so they'll feel okay and yet it
didn't really help them instead we have
to tell them the truth on this show
and sometimes
you're so harsh you know i just love you
enough to tell you the truth because i
want you to be better after our
conversation which would be better after
i give you this check and so if i'm
giving money to your brother for rent
and to my brother for rent if i'm you
it's gonna sound like okay
here's what this comes with
okay we're all trying to survive this
train wreck of a family
and we're all trying to get better and
i'm willing to help you with your rent
if you get better and that means you're
going to get on a budget and you're
going to send me a copy of the budget
before i send you the money
and you're going to promise me that
you're going to read this total money
makeover book or you're going to go to
this financial peace university class
i'll pay for it but you've got to go
you've got to get better i'm going to
use the money as leverage in their life
to lift them
not taking advice not to participate in
their stuff and let's be honest the
response is going to be who do you think
you are oh mr fancy and you're going to
say i'm your brother and i love you
exactly
you don't owe an explanation for who i
think i am is i think i'm the guy with
the money over here that cares about you
and i love you that's right
i care about you and so i'm gonna dangle
this money right in front of your
freaking nose to help you can i tell you
this to be prepared for clayton
one or two of them of your siblings
won't take it and you will be the bad
guy
for trying to make long-term help
okay prepare your heart for that and
that doesn't mean that you failed that
means that they're still struggling
right yeah
um yeah that's understood yeah when you
won't participate in their deal then
they go there
and so you know the thing is this um
the version of you that they create
in their head
is not your responsibility
if they want to make you into the
villain
and they say you you can't control
somebody making you into a villain when
you're doing the right thing that's
going to happen sometimes you do the
right thing and people call you villain
that's right and they they write a
narrative in their own brain that you're
a villain and they don't get a vote then
you know you just don't understand
you're not like a real part of our
family
you know and
you uh you didn't got uppity hadn't you
you know and all this stuff and yeah uh
yeah whatever that's exactly what
happened i guess but what really
happened is i love you so much i ain't
participating in crazy no more bud
that's what we're doing some true help
yeah and that's not tough love that's
real love